nuevamente Bienvenidos en el video
anterior nos quedamos en cómo estas dos
fórmulas están relacionadas Ya que en
este
punto es lo mismo que si dejaramos caer
la pelota directamente al suelo a una
altura
H Así que esta fórmula hace lo mismo que
esta otra que inferimos en el video
anterior en el video anterior si dejamos
caer la pelota esta velocidad inicial es
igual a cer y la distancia hacia abajo
sería - H bueno recordamos entonces que
también esta el periodo o el tiempo no
es el tiempo completo sino solo la mitad
en esta sección Entonces tenemos que
nuestra altura - H hacia abajo es igual
a la
gravedad por el periodo que es el tiempo
cer entre
do al
cuadrado todo esto entre 2 si si
multiplicamos por menos un ambos
términos tendremos exactamente esta
misma fómula
eso es genial Ya que en la física
siempre tenemos muchísimas formas de
encontrar una solución podemos comenzar
con cualquiera de las fórmulas que hemos
visto y mientras ustedes no hagan nada
incorrecto y se pongan a jugar con ellas
y a pensar en ellas ustedes podrán
Encontrar la ruta más rápida a la
solución siempre y cuando no hagan nada
incorrecto ustedes siempre llegarán a la
solución Espero que esto les haya dado
una mejor comprensión sobre el
movimiento de proyectiles en el
siguiente conjunto de videos veremos
problemas un poco más complicados y un
poco más realistas comenzaremos a ver
los problemas en dos dimensiones y no
solo cuando lanzamos algo arriba abajo
sino cuando le hacamos algo con cierto
ángulo como normalmente sucede nos
veremos en el siguiente video